forgive me father as i have sinned
these are words you're going to be
saying if you don't take caution while
watching these risky anime yep you read
the title right folks so grab your
favorite brand of tissues keep the door
closed and make sure your viewing device
of choice isn't connected to the
speakers downstairs well you're
definitely going to be asking for
forgiveness this sunday please note
these titles are listed from our
personal preference and not an official
ranking however feel free to share your
favorite etsy shows with the boys in the
comment section
[Music]
we kick it off with samurai gills with
this gorgeous landscape and prosperous
people great japan is the envy of all
other nations as it should be but a
serious threat hovers over the webland
other than sjw's and the only defense is
mysterious guardians known as master
samurai and here comes the man with the
golden stick
[Applause]
he makes his way to the buoy academic
school upon arriving at the school the
power of the harem king starts going and
our dude gets kissed by a mysterious
girl that appears from nowhere and with
it she awakens an unknown power that
protects him i call it the power of
horny on a more serious note the show is
kind of okay the plot and execution
aren't the best but it could have been
worse however samurai girls shine the
most in the art style and how unique it
is and the fan service is all right
[Music]
next up is the 2021 hit show redo of
gila i trust 99 of you know the premise
of the show so here's just a quick
summary the mc gained his powers as a
hero who specialized in healing or
injuries he gets abused endlessly and
the mad lad becomes too op he unleashes
a powerful healing spell to rewound the
entire world to the time before he began
to suffer his horrible fate and just
like that the epic story about
determination perseverance and revenge
begins making this show that isn't good
enough to be labeled as an age anime a
perfect fit to be on this list
at number eight we have a blast from the
past freezing going into the show i
thought oh well i'll watch another feel
good etchy show and with chicks like
untouchable queed expectations of
brainless fun were high
oh boy was i wrong the story takes place
decades into the future humanity is
under siege by an alien race known as
the novas to combat them young women
known as pandoras and young men known as
limiters are implanted with stigmata to
give them superhuman powers and are
trained in military academies where they
must learn to work together if humanity
is to have a chance of surviving now at
the time i should have read the plot but
i stupidly didn't and what awaited me
wasn't this fun brainless edgy harem
show but a dramatic edgy show with
pretty dark moments that would make you
want to punch a hole in the wall now i'm
not saying it's bad on the contrary
actually it's one of my personal
favorites i'm saying if you haven't
watched this series yet make sure you've
got your stress ball within arm's reach
ps the specials are fun and
light-hearted so don't miss them too
[Music]
the quasar of stigmata
after rumors of a serial killer
attacking female student spreads a girl
gets attacked in a burning church by the
rumored serial killer he attacks her
with a mysterious ability to control
magnesium
appearing out of nowhere is a
silver-haired boy who can control iron
and after the cool looking guy rescues
the girl from the creepy looking guy the
big bull by chick finds out the emo boy
is a quasa a being who's capable of
controlling an element through the power
received through the act of
breastfeeding such is the story of
quasar of stigmata of course of course
the baby male will find his way to this
list because when a grown-ass man sucks
on women oppai to replenish his power it
must be uncensored and watched alone and
believe it or not people tend to judge a
lot even if they say no judgment one day
you're playing dodgeball with the boys
that makes you sitting on the swing
alone because they're dodging you
yo mirror
i mean the anime that made this small
youtuber cry nozoki anna kido an art
student discovers a crack in his wall
shortly after moving into his new
apartment when he looks inside he makes
eye contact with his next-door neighbor
who happens to be enjoying her god-given
lady parts and like the dumb [ __ ] our
main man is he rushes next door to clear
up the misunderstanding and informs her
of the crack but trips and falls over in
the process
what a sad day to be a gentleman to make
matters worse the lady now has
pornographic evidence that clearly shows
kido to be a sexual offender hence she
blackmails him into leaving the crack as
is because it turns out this wild chick
has a fetish called voyeurism meaning
she gains your pleasure from watching
others when they're naked or engaged in
activity now with such a premise like
this you think the show is all about
water sports and it do be like that
however the manga is something else if
you're looking for a good story
alongside the booba the manga is the way
as the anime skipped almost every plot
point that doesn't include the doom
from here on all the names of fan
favorites and it would be a noob move if
you didn't recognize them two love root
follows rito a guy who can't confess to
his crush but with the power of the pen
and the writers on his side he scores a
hot alien princess however like all
godly gifts there's a downside as our
boy rito's peaceful life turns into
daily struggles with the bizarre chaos
that begins upon the arrival of the
princess with an ever-growing legion of
swooning beauties that continuously foil
his attempted confessions to his
childhood crush tulavru is a romantic
comedy full of slapstick humor sexy
girls and outlandish lewd moments that
defy the laws of physics
[Music]
[Applause]
next we have the testament of sister new
devil basara learns the hard way that
running into your new stepsister in the
bathroom isn't the best way to make a
good first impression when his father
unexpectedly brings home two beautiful
girls and introduces them as his new
siblings he has no choice but to accept
the busty redhead mio and petite
silverhead maria into his family basara
is forced to reveal himself as a former
member of a clan of heroes sworn enemies
of the demons when these seemingly
normal girls reveal themselves as demons
now for most the testament of sister new
devil was their gateway to echiharam
anime making it a classic in that genre
at number three we have a personal
favorite security this criminally
underrated show in the harem genre tells
the story of a struggling yet brilliant
basic harem lead after failing the
entrance exams for the second time the
main man gets labelled as a sakura
worthless however the curse of the
sakura is altered dramatically when a
beautiful supernatural woman falls from
the sky and into his life that woman is
a unique being known as a secure a
humanoid extraterrestrial with
extraordinary abilities these aliens are
known for kissing humans to awaken
additional latent powers deep within
which they use to duke it out in a
high-stakes competition now if you
haven't watched this show yet then what
the frick are you doing here at 2am
don't skip sekiro put it on hold it's
not the best anime out there but it's so
goddamn entertaining to binge watch
alone
second is none other than the number one
harem show high school dxd and like
radio of heather i trust 99 of you are
familiar with the show so here's a quick
rundown resident loser issei is a major
perv with no game just like his loser
friends who start to envy him when a
beautiful girl asks him out on a date
but like all nice girls she turns out to
be a c word
he says words not mine and she brutally
ends his life however after going out
like a virgin he gets a second chance at
life when beautiful busty riaz who's a
top-class devil revives him as her
servant and just like that our boy turns
from a loser who can't score a date to a
harem king who can't go past second base
[Music]
and at number one the undying edgy
classic prison school why is it number
one you might ask well it was my gateway
not only to edgy anime but also just
anime in general before prison school i
used to watch a couple of shows here and
there on the tv like the average anime
enjoyer but after this series i became a
full-on otaku wii bingeing shows till
four to five in the morning so it had to
be prison school at number one and spare
you the details that you already know
i'll just say it's about a group of boys
who couldn't conquer the horny so they
get bonked and went to horny jail
and that's about it for this list hope
you enjoyed the video and we'll be
looking forward to your feedback for
upcoming content so don't forget to like
and comment until next time stay safe
and stay weeb